مرحبا بكم قناه الجزيره اعلنت الولايات
المتحده والمانيا تقديمه مساعدات عسكريه
جديده لاوكرانيا
قتاليه من طراز برادي ومدرعات الالمانيه
من طراز بارده واكد البلدان في بيان
المشتركه عزمهما على تقديم المساعدات
العسكريه جديده لكيف تتضمن مركبات قتاليه
ومنظومات الدفاع جوي وبطاريه الدفاع الجوي
اضافيا من طرازي بتروت
وقال رئيس الامريكي
تمر بمرحله
اعلنا للكريم لان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين دعا على الجانب الاوكراني الى
الاعلان عن الهدنه ووقف اطلاق النار لمنح
الناس فرصه الاحتفال بعيد الميلاد وحضور
الصلوات او عزاء رئيس الروسي لوزير الدفاع
الجوي بوقف اطلاق النار في كل الجبهات
المواجهه في اوكرانيا ابتداءا من الساعه
الثانيه عشر من ظهره اليوم الجمعه وحتى
منتصف ليله الغد
وقد اعتبر الرئيس الامريكي
يبحث عن فرصه للتنفس بينما قالت وزير
الخارجيه الالمانيه الخطوه الروسيه لم
تجلد الحريه ولا الامام
وطلب المستشار ورئاسه الاوكرانيه تيموفي
ميلابو نوفا في مقابله مع الجزيره روسيا
بسحب قواتها واخلاء الاراضي الاخرانيه قبل
الحديث عنه اضافنا شروط اوكرانيا لوقف
اطلاق النار لم تتغير منذ بدا روسي حربها
عليها وانه على يقين بان الاوكرانيين
سيحررون كل اراضيهم بالوسائل العسكريه او
الدبلوماسيه
وصف مساعد الامين العام لشؤون الشرق
الاوسط واسيا والمحيط الهادئ خالد خياري
زيارته وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
لاثمار بن كثير للاماكن المقدسه
بالتحريضيه لانه دعا الى تغيير الوضع
التاريخي في القدس و خلال جلسه طارئه
لمجلس الامن لبحثه تطورات في مدينه القدس
اضافه المسؤول الامميه وان الوضع في
الاماكن المقدسه هش وان اي حادثه يمكن ان
يؤجل في المنطقه
الامريكيه في الامم المتحده روبرتو عن
قلقه من اي اعمال الاحاديه الجانب قد تؤدي
الى تفاقم التوتر او تقود حل دولتين من
ناحيته قاده المندوب الفلسطيني رياض منصور
الى تصرفات الاسرائيلي لن تؤدي الى
استسلام الفلسطينيين الى انتفاضه
قال عميد المحامين التونسيين حاتم مسيو
الى المحاماه
ستتصدى لكل اشكال الاستبداد ولن تقبل
بالارتداد عن مكاسب الثوره وفي وقفه
احتجاجيه للمحامين امام قصر العداله شدد
مزيده على ان المحامين التونسيين يرفضون
تبعيه القضاء لاي جهه سياسيه
وقال الامين العام المساعد للاتحاد
التونسي للشغل سام الطاهرين الاتحاد لم
يقبل بمقايضه الاستقرار بالاستبدال اضافه
الطاهر ان القطع مع الاحزاب ولا يمكنه من
العمليه الديمقراطيه
[موسيقى]
في المقابل قال رئيس التونسيه قصص سعيد ان
الحريه لا تعني الفوضى والتامر على امن
الدوله الداخلي والخارجي وفق تعبيري واتهم
سعيد خلال لقائه وزير الداخليه تونسي جهات
لم يسميها بتلقي مبالغ الضخمه من الخارج
لتاجيج الاوضاع وضرب استقرار الدوله
التونسيه
[موسيقى]